Heyeveryonedogan
hereUMSoIspeakany
Japanesebutrecently
onTwitterIseenalot
ofvideosofpeople
usingAItokindofmake
themselvesspeak
otherlanguagesSoI
thoughtItryanddothe
sameThingwith
Japaneseandina
secondwegnadothatto
thisveryVideoWhatdo
youthinkareyou
impressed disappointedLetme
knowUMWhatELseIam35
yearsoldAmericanand
bornandraisedInThe
StateOf
washington
Iknowinthenear
futurelovetovisit
JapanIReallyWantTo
SeeThetemplesthe
shine sandjustkind
experienceThe
richnessOfThe
cultureANDTHE
HISTORY
handokIthinkwaitto
seeHowITturnsOUTHello everyone, I
love anime and
hentai.  I can't do it, but recently
on Twitter I saw a lot of people
using AI to create videos of themselves speaking foreign languages, or
erotic videos of anime characters like waves and the night, and I thought I'd like to
try it myself.  That's what I thought.And
after this, I'd like to use this footage to
conduct some of the tests.Hello, everyone, have you been
watching early Freele recently
or have you been watching Attack on Titan?  Well,
I'm
35 years old, American, and have spent more than half of my life
as an otaku.I'm
not feeling well today after washing my face.I'd
like to go to Japan soon, especially at Japanese convenience stores.  I'd like to see a
Japanese woman in person and then take a
selfie at the Scramble Crossing store in Shibuya.I
think that's all.By the way,
that's me.